so many of you ask me what business  should I start and I've been talking  about scratching your own itch my entire  career anytime I'm with friends family  founders  youngsters people in transition in their  30s 40s 50s who are looking to start  something this title matters a lot to me  I was pumped when I saw it made me want  to make a video so many of you actually  have your business idea based on the  inconvenience and frustrations of your  day-to-day something's like I don't like  that oh that'd be awesome if that  experience kind of sucked it'd be cool  if it was those kind of sentences are  usually the seed of ideas that become  profound businesses  scratch your own itch I don't like the  way this is I wish it could have been  like that  start with that insight and build from  there someone's going to start a big  business off this video and I'm pretty  pumped about it